ya hemos visto que una función efe mapea
elementos del dominio mapea elementos
del dominio dominio del lujo es decir si
te tomas un elemento de su dominio la
función lo mapea a un elemento de su
codo humilló a un elemento del
condominio de lujo como mi guión así que
si por ejemplo nosotros tomamos por aquí
el conjunto del dominio y bueno déjame
hacerlo con color anaranjado por aquí me
voy a tomar
el dominio de esta función y bueno vamos
a tomar algunos elementos de manera
aleatoria por aquí
imagínate que este es el uno o que por
acá tengo al menos uno ok por acá
imaginad que me tomo al siete y por acá
por acá se me antoja tomarme a pie ok
ahora todos estos son miembros del
dominio de efe a una imagínate que
tenemos por acá el condominio
y déjame hacerlo con este color por acá
tenemos el dominio y ahora digamos que f
mapea al 1 o de otra manera
efe de 1 f1 lo manda para acá y toma el
valor de menos 3 va a tomar aquí el
valor de menos 3
es decir que f de uno es igual a menos 3
o ese mapea al 1 al valor de menos 3
ahora imagínate también que f mapea al
número menos 1 mapea al número menos 1
al valor de 7 ok
efe - 17 vamos a suponer eso y también
vamos a suponer que f mapea al 7
efe de 7 va a ser igual a 10 ok
supongamos que es igual a 10 y por
último vamos a decir que fdp que fdp
también toma el valor de 10
también tomar el valor de 10 así que
aquí tenemos el mapeo de la función y lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta es
que es una función legítima porque
recuerda que para que tengamos una
función para cada una de las entradas se
tiene que mapear a una única salida a
sólo una salida esto no sería una
función si pasara algo como esto si f
bueno nosotros sabemos que f de pin de
fdp es lo mismo que 10 y esto lo hace
una función ojo porque estamos mapeando
a pin al 10
la entrada pin sabemos que vamos a
obtener una única salida que es 10 pero
si estuviéramos haciendo aquí un tipo de
relación que no fuera función y déjame
quitar esto de aquí pasaría algo así
pues si ponemos a pie algunas veces me
va a dar 10 pero tal vez otras veces me
dé el valor de 11 y en este momento ya
no es una función esto no va a ser una
función porque estamos mapeando a pin
primero al valor de 10 y después al
valor de 11 y esto no es correcto si
queremos pensar en una función recuerda
para cada entrada le vamos a mapear
solamente una salida una sola ojo
podemos tener como en este caso dos
entradas que se maten a una misma salida
pero nosotros sabemos en este caso que f
de 7 es lo mismo que 10 y también
sabemos que f
y también toma el valor de 10 ahora lo
que quiero ver en este vídeo es cuando
una función no es invertible ya hemos
visto que la inversa es una función es
un mapeo entre un elemento del
condominio con su respectivo elemento
del dominio así que la inversa debe
mapear al menos 3 al 1 la inversa de f
ok
efe inversa debe mapear al menos 3 al
valor de 1 y esto es porque am y déjame
ponerlo así porque sabemos que f de 1 f1
esto es exactamente igual a menos 3 y
por lo tanto efe inversa y déjame
ponerlo cuando este color
efe inversa de menos 3 y ojo efe inversa
también debe de ser una función y por lo
tanto debe cumplir las mismas
propiedades que una función por lo tanto
debe mapear al menos 3
una cosa en este caso efe inversa de
menos 3 es 1 efe inversa de menos 3 es 1
y bueno aquí ya tenemos una idea de qué
va a pasar con el 7
efe inversa de 7 va a ser igual a menos
1 recuerda que esta es f inversa efe
inversa es inversa de 7 va a ser igual a
menos 1 y eso tiene mucho sentido porque
nosotros sabíamos que f de menos 1 esto
era igual a 7 y ahora podemos escribir
que f inversa que f inversa de 7 ok esto
me va a llevar al valor de menos 1 ok
pero ahora algo muy interesante pasa
justo aquí cuál debería de ser el valor
que tomaría f inversa de 10
si yo trato de mapear al 10 existen dos
elementos del dominio que cuando yo
aplico la función me van a dar
en el condominio por lo tanto la
pregunta sería quién sería la función
inversa de 10 ahora si tú tratas de ver
qué efecto invertible entonces la
función inversa debería mapear a este
elemento a este elemento a solo un
elemento del dominio pero en este caso
lo mapea a dos elementos del dominio así
que f inversa de 10 esto es igual a 7 o
esto es igual a ti es justo lo raro que
tenemos aquí y en este caso como la
función inversa no puede hacer que los
elementos del dominio se maten
únicamente a una cosa entonces decimos
que esta función no es invertible y
dejar ponerlo aquí esta función
es invertible y déjame ponerlo aquí y
ver
y bueno esto pasa porque el mapeo
inverso del co dominio al dominio la
relación inversa no es una función pues
no podemos tomarnos a cualquier elemento
de nuestro dominio y que se mapea un
único elemento de nuestro dominio pues
el 10 no sabemos si se va a mapear api o
se va a mapear a 7 así que esta función
efe que recuerda que es una función
porque cada uno de sus elementos del
dominio está bien definido a un único
elemento de su co dominio pero el camino
de regreso no es cierto para la función
inversa a cada elemento de este
condominio de este conjunto no va a solo
un elemento de este otro conjunto pues
el 10 se puede mapear a 7 o api así que
otra forma de verlo sería la siguiente
efe no es invertible
no es invertible no es una es invertible
aunque f si sea función pero el mapeo
inverso no es una función y por lo tanto
f no es invertible